después de que la maquinaria legal rusa
hablase la maquinaria legal legislativa
culmina hoy la anexión de los cuatro
territorios ucranianos ocupados en este
momento parcialmente por las tropas
rusas luans y también las nuevas
conquistas de Putin de gerson y
saborilla aún así las fronteras
occidentales de Rusia Siguen sin estar
claras en un momento en el que el
ejército ucraniano Está realizando
nuevos avances no solo en la región de
doniach sino también en gerson donde las
tropas ucranianas van empujando poco a
poco hacia el sur hasta acorralar a los
soldados rusos el presidente ucraniano
Por cierto os doy michelinsky ha dicho
que entra en vigor su decisión de
prohibir como si fuese un asunto de
seguridad nacional establecer
conversaciones o negociaciones con Rusia
mientras vladmir Putin sea presidente
aquí en Moscú sigue adelante el
reclutamiento no solo entre personas con
que hayan hecho el servicio militar sino
también con personas sin experiencia
Aunque lo admitir Putin ha prometido
corregir los errores del principio